hello I'm the moving screen your source
for all basketball information welcome
to the all Hero Drive fun available
players include Jeff Moran wow the best
villain in the west I'd rather roll with
Shannon sharp Joel embiid wow the best
villain in the east ah the Flopper
respect Nicola jokic oh he's so good
they are going to stop giving him MVPs
in there Luca don't judge me and Luca
the officials wouldn't stand a chance
Jason Tatum oh boy it'll be tough for me
to get past this year oh yeah tremendous
Defender
free marketing they got fans in the all
Hero game Donovan Mitchell oh now the
Cavs will trade for a star Kyrie Irving
at last Josiah can't keep us apart oh
and this just in Kyrie's recently
sparked a lot of attention with his
latest social media oh no delete it what
are you doing don't show it
[Music]